you don't hold accountability to my pain
you're being a Karen I'm talking about
I'm talking to the pain I'm not a cow
and I'm not going to cancel you and I'm
not going to answer you I'm simply going
to challenge you on what you're saying I
think you don't understand the pain that
you've been causing with some of these
comments and I think that one in
particular I can understand God God
forbid God forbid one comment could
cause people to feel any of the pain
that my people have went through for
years even like the blacks being ushered
to the left during the Civil Rights
Movement no one is cared
okay no all right no one is can I let me
say I agree that the racism against
black people has been utterly deplorable
shameful unacceptable and thank God the
world is beginning to move to a better
place
people like you however however one form
of racism
I was in a position where I've been hurt
and this is the way I had the right to
express myself the point of this
interview is for you to question me and
then for me to answer and say okay even
though the same rules are not applied to
my people if a person with a gun or
drugs is pulled over and has four three
other people in the car they're all
going to jail I'm not going to apply
that to Jewish people for the sake of
this conversation isn't that what you
wanted but you know what you did you
tried the Civil Rights me you tried to
pull me back to a week ago but we're
here today there's been plenty of
Commerce conversations of commentary
since that but you want me to go back to
1960.7 days ago let me jump in here's
what I want you to do I want you to okay
so have we grown have we have we have we
grown yes how we grow here's how we grow
I want you to reflect have we grown I'm
about to be growing I'm not in charge of
my growth United charging I'm about to
okay like this I'm about to suggest to
you how you may grow if you choose to
grow this way and you can you can ignore
me you can ignore me Pierce Pierce how
much money are you worth not as much as
you sadly
exactly so take my advice maybe you'll
get richer I would love to take your
businesses why would I listen to you
well why do you why do you handle my
advice is and then work out if I'm wrong
can we do that deal
well the thing is you you haven't given
me any credit or a moment of reflection
for the comparison that I made the
brilliant if I do say so myself
comparison that I made to the cops
pulling over one black person and
locking up in my tweet having issues I
always said I wasn't done with the
sentence
my tweet referring to all Jewish people
I said for the sake of this conversation
I will refer to the business people who
have destroyed me and my people and my
fellow creatives but you didn't even
accept that I gave you that you tried to
push me back into 1960. no you tried to
push me back into last week no I didn't
okay if you accept that example that I
gave you I understand completely the
example you gave me I think all racism
is wrong I just will that we've grown I
would like you to reflect a few years
if you've now changed what you wanted to
say originally my question for you is do
you now regret saying
on Jewish people are you sorry you said
that
it matters you should be absolutely not
you know
I will say I'm sorry for the people that
I heard with the Defcon the the
confusion that I call I feel like I call
I cause hurt and confusion and I'm sorry
for the families of the people that had
nothing to do with the the trauma that I
had been through and that I use my
platform where you say hurt people hurt
people and I I was hurt it's an
uncensored interview you said something
which you've now wished you hadn't said
and you've apologized I actually think
that says a lot about you right that
shows you've got that ability to be
self-aware to understand when you cross
a line I think someone like you with all
your energy and creativity and your
passion you're gonna say stuff the way
that you talk constantly and in such an
extraordinary manner you're gonna trip
up you're going to say things the wrong
way I don't think there's anything wrong
and when you do that doing what you just
did and saying I'm sorry I crossed a
line I apologize I want to say that it's
wrong to hold an apology hostage and and
I gotta let go of that and free you know
free myself of the trauma and say look
I'm just gonna give it all up to God
right now and say to those families that
I heard you know I really want to give
you guys a big hug and I want to uh I
say I'm sorry for hurting you with my
comments and I want to word it and not a
pres and not like a political way but in
a presidential way which means what I
knew a president to be when I was
growing up